all right okay challenge is off eric
i can't remember last time we played
yeah it's been a while
i don't think we've ever played a proper
match no
hello to uh eric's youtube audience by
the way potentially
yeah hello to twitch chat
oh you play this line i remember you
played this against pates
i was preparing for pates
you're streaming this on twitch too no
i'm not streaming um
except we'll be on twitch in the future
right
oh you mean yes yes so future twitch
all right down in exchange is a good
start
ah i'm nervous are you nervous kind of
nervous
uh you know a little bit i can't tell if
it's the coffee or just my normal uh
heart rate you doing you drink coffee
the slate at night
oh yeah it's a bad habit i know
oh my pawn it's so hard to talk and play
you can take all my pawns if you want
i'm gonna try
i was hoping to induce at least one doc
comment from you
so we got that at least
i guess i'm still up the exchange ah
oh that was foolish for me
no no
i might as well like pray for stalemate
right
just a normal sloppy bully game huh yeah
no i was so proud of the opening
preparation
you are the stalemate master all it
takes is one mouse slip
ah okay good game okay
okay and it's hard to to trash talk and
play
right all right rematch oh i forgot i
forgot
i you think of all the openings i could
remember i would remember stafford
gambit but
we're not uh i just wanted like one
staffer gambit accepted
i locked up your games though and you
don't really you don't accept it ever
you always decline it i don't think i've
hardly ever faced it
to be honest but yeah that sounds
accurate
as a practical matter i would not take
it
no i did a little bit of preparation for
you and i saw
you've ran into it maybe ten times
oh wow okay done your research
i'm gonna grab this part so great i'm
gonna give it a shot
oh i gotta take that one too so i'm so
broken right now
oh my gosh oh
i'm so broke you guys just devoid the
stafford and you're all good
i don't know what it is like i'm okay
i'm gonna repeat the same line because
that was good earlier
yeah that did work out well for you i'm
gonna oh okay take special care here i
hope a6
making a mid-match adjustment so i
basically played a
two-game gambit trying to give you a
false sense of confidence
right this is what happened in my well
okay i don't want to spoil anything oh
yeah don't don't spoil
but if you want to spoil this position
that would be nice
always play f3 oh you got f4 there
oh so much regrets
ah my pawn
i'm losing another pawn too okay let's
go for this
gotta do it right
i just want to break through there we go
business
i feel like moses
partying the red sea yeah
oh rook b4 would not be good there
okay we're taking the long route here
how are you so fast i was thinking the
same thing
about you that is
wow you're so fast thanks man
that was well played thanks eric i feel
like
i just got swept
well you did you're like a broom